[Music]
hello and welcome inside Katy Perry
headquarters she will be broadcasting
live all weekend long from inside this
house I'm in the monitor room right now
where you can see all 41 of the cameras
that capture every one of Katie's moves
and here's the cool thing I had a chance
to go and talk to Katie alright cadence
playing the house why do this why expose
your entire world to the world sometimes
people don't see people like myself as
humans and it's nice to show that I'm a
human because I think if you realize
that I'm a human then you also realize
that you can dream as big as I could
dream last night Katy Perry kicked off a
live streaming stunt to launch her new
album witness but just an hour later her
rival Taylor Swift made a bold
calculated move I didn't say I didn't
warn ya Swift re-released her entire
music catalog to Spotify and other
streaming services
Alix Gale is the executive editor of
complex Taylor putting her music on all
streaming services especially Spotify is
a huge deal she's the biggest pop star
out and she was really the last holdout
from streaming it does make you scratch
your head these two about a long-running
beef
despite Taylor's tactic Katy's album
witness shot to number one on iTunes
early this morning it includes the song
swish-swish which is widely seen as a
swipe at Taylor swish swish fish
so how did all this start well Taylor
seemed to be talking about Perry in 2014
when she told Rolling Stone an unnamed
celebrity quote basically tried to
sabotage an entire arena tour Katy told
James Corden the feud was started by a
rift over backup dancers honestly it's
really like she started it and it's time
for her to finish it and I tried to talk
to her about it and she she wouldn't
speak it was a full shutdown and she
writes a song about Metis baby
Katie didn't stop there in a new
interview with NME magazine Perry said
quote I mean I'm not Buddha things
irritate me I wish that I could turn the
other cheek every single time but I'm
also not a pushover you know especially
when someone tries to assassinate my
character with little girl that's so
messed up
[Music]
you